your life bonjour on est en direct ce
mardi
sion celle des données dans le football
et avec moi aujourd'hui tout d'abord
sébastien ferra bonjour sébastien salut
vincent salut à tous aujourd'hui vous
signé dans le journal du jour un article
très intéressant comment les data sont
en train de révolutionner la ligue 1 a
retrouvé toujours si votre marchand de
journaux dans pour cet article du figaro
et je suis également avec enzo jebali
bonjour un jour ex-responsable son
adjoint de la cellule du recrutement du
stade de reims on va parler un peu de
votre travail de comment ça fonctionne
dans les clubs de ligue 1 dans les clubs
internationaux comment voilà qu'est ce
que c'est que ces métiers parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne voit pas
forcément mais qui n'est pas le plus
connu pour l'instant en tout cas tout en
live vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser
vos questions on essaiera de répondre au
mieux bien évidemment comme d'habitude
déjà est-ce qu'on peut définir un peu de
quoi on parle quand on parle de stats de
de données dans le football la stat tout
simplement c'est les éléments qui vont
permettre de quantifier les actions
lorsque lorsqu'on parle de statistiques
un peu basique on va quantifier le
nombre de passes quentin quantifier le
nombre de ballons ce qu'on voit un petit
peu à la télévision
et c'est un peu le point zéro de la
statistique le point de départ de la
statistique on prend les éléments et on
décortique au fur à mesure faut savoir
que déjà dans les 70 le fait de compter
les buts on s'était dit qu'on s'était
décidée a déjà dit dans la réflexion que
ce n'était pas assez donc on a commencé
à réfléchir au concept de passes
décisives s'est démocratisée à partir
des années 80 90 et à partir de ce
moment là on a eu on a commencé à
séquencer de plus en plus les
statistiques un peu dans le football qui
est un sport extrêmement fluide
contrairement à d'autres sports au final
les statistiques sont arrivés plus tôt
tard dans le football dans qu'est ce que
c'est que les statistiques c'est tout
simplement dans le football c'était
simplement quantifier c'est la
quantification des actions dans
des actions ti paul typologie coûts
typiques dans le sport cette fête les
pas ça peut être les contrôles de balle
ça peut être les tirs c'est peut-être du
coup peut entrer dans le détail des tirs
découle des tirs cadrés et tient à
recadrer les duels défensifs au sol en
l'air bref au filet au fur et à mesure
que justement on avance dans dans la
réflexion et dans la réflexion et dans
la typologie des statistiques on a des
statistiques de plus en plus détaillée
est de plus en plus poussées sur la
quantification de ces chiffres là oui
par exemple on entend peu après par
l'essai ligue j'ai par exemple qui à la
place des buts c'est
sébastien peut-être on peut en parler de
ces fameux dj on voit les buts et c'est
le nombre de buts que l'équipe aurait dû
marquer en fait c'est ça c'est alors que
j'ai c'est à dire expected gauche donc
expected gaulle ça se traduirait
littéralement par l'ue du tant attendu
même maintenant aussi les expected
assiste c'est assez assez développée
donc les inspecteurs gaulle ça serait a
priori le nombre de but qu'un joueur
aurait pu marquer qu'une équipe aurait
dû marquer en se basant sur tout un tas
de tout un tas de statistiques avant ça
en essayant d'analyser la position du
joueur au moment de son tir la situation
adverse la position du gardien des
défenseurs la distance par rapport au
but c'est un petit peu ça c'est cesser
de en fait de calculer la qualité d'une
occasion un petit peu oui alors
justement en fait c'est on va en parler
c'est justement le lamente le côté heat
j'ai en fait c'est à dire le fait de
ceux de réduire les statistiques en fait
à une ne plus plus à une donnée à une
probabilité 7 ce prisme là de la
probabilité c'est justement l'entrée
dans la statistique 2.0 dans le football
ça veut dire qu'on
réfléchisse à qu'est ce qui fait un bon
attaquant c'est d'ailleurs été le fait
la traduction d'un itron arrive est-ce
que les attaquants qui marquent le plus
sont pas forcément les plus chères donc
alors comment qu'on quantifie un bon
attaquant est ce qu'il marque des buts
bon ça rend compte que finalement il
marque des buts il est le meilleur
buteur c'est bien mais est ce qu'il
apporte dans le jeu suffisamment en tout
c'est donc on se dit on a commencé après
a poussé encore le curseur un peu plus
sur sa vie on va séparer les tirs des
tirs cadrés par exemple alors s'il cadre
beaucoup c'est bien ça veut dire qu'il
est précis donc c'est un bon buteur et
cetera on a continué un petit peu dans
la réflexion football et on s'est dit
oui mais d'accord s'il fait un tir cadré
et que ça va dans les gants du gardien
et que ça n'apporte pas de danger alors
qu'il ya une autre frappe de 30 mètres
par exemple qui est dangereuse qui met
en danger le canadien n'est pas cadrée
et ça touche la barre est ce que cette
frappe là une qualité quand même
supérieur à une frappe molle ou 20
mètres aux cinq mètres karaté et qui est
fait et qui finit dans les bras du
gardien donc du coup en fait on a
renversé la question de la donner par la
question football ça veut dire au lieu
de se dire
quelles sont les données on se dit
quelle est l'utilité quelle est la
question football qui répond à à l'idée
est donc le côté probabilité donc
expects est donc attendue est devenu le
nouveau prisme dans la data pour
comparer et comprendre ce que va
apporter un joueur est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui donc l'expective cole est
justement dans une situation donnée par
exemple un penalty vous avez 79 % de
chances de marquer voilà donc du coup en
expected gaulle donc sur le si on
considère que l'indicé 1 vous avez 0 1
919 expecting 11 01 79 buts attendu donc
là on s'attend de vous que vous ayez 70%
de chances de marquer mais on peut même
aller plus loin dans la logique on peut
se dire dans une situation donnée par
rapport aux tirs qu'il a effectuée
si par exemple dans une position donnée
il ya 5 % de chances de marquer de but
mais qu'avec 7 5% de chances de marquer
deux buts il a effectué un tir que on va
dire 80 % des gaules des gardiens de but
n'arrive pas à arrêter eh bien on a un
poste expects et goes on a on a un but
attendu après le but attendu et donc on
arrive justement est logique où on se
dit eh bien
on avance dans la probabilité dans
l'étude de la probabilité on continue de
ce2 de
soumettre la data à des questions
football attend on adapte beaucoup de
raisonnement mathématique exactement
l'envol parce que c'est que moi j'ai vu
qu'on regarde des matchs en général sur
sur tf1 et canal+ on a des statistiques
qui sont nombre de balles reçues dont 2
le père du saas et des données
finalement qui ont plus vraiment de sens
aujourd'hui on peut lire
des données qui apporte un petit peu
moins parce que ce sont des données
assez en surface quand par exemple
effectivement le nombre de tirs de tirs
cadrés c'est justement le but un peu des
data c'est d'aller plus loin dans
l'analyse et d'analysé souvent la
qualité de ces situations une équipe
peut avoir 20 tirs mais ça peut être 20
tirs on n'a jamais eu le sentiment que
ça pouvait vraiment finir au fond si ce
sont 20 tirs avec à chaque fois une
valeur des spectacles c'est extrêmement
faible forcément sa maman de la valeur
mais pour le grand public ça peut à
donner le sentiment d'une énorme
domination et d'une équipe qui aurait
largement mérité de gagner ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas le mot clé en fait
c'est la contextualisation c'est
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un peu le
problème qu'on a eu justement avec les
données brutes auparavant
lorsque par exemple c'est dans l'article
qui est écrit quand on admire la
capacité à marco garatti de toucher 120
130 140 ballon dans le match oui c'est
parce qu'il est dans une équipe qui a
énormément la possession qui du coup en
plus de sa grâce à ses capacités
techniques des vite dans les petits
périmètres d'évitement de l'adversaire
grâce à sa capacité à mettre le corps en
opposition qui sont hors normes du coup
beaucoup de ballons passent par la
recouvrir ati et donc c'est en fait
c'est la conséquence technique que les
140 ballon c'est la conséquence
technique et donc du coup en fait on
oublie de columbia contextualisations en
fait et aujourd'hui les données en
probabilités ne permettre de
contextualiser ça veut dire ok c'est
bien sûr une équipe qui est dominante
comme le psg c'est bien effectivement
qu'un joueur comme marque envers haïti
et touche beaucoup de ballons mais est
ce qu'on a sur la filière offensives
d'une équipe beaucoup plus de
difficultés à posséder ballon
ni régulière si un joueur la plus
souvent si un joueur a plus souvent un
ballon si un joueur a le ballon sous
pression son analyse les contrôles
orientés qu'il fait
voilà on avance déjà dans des données
qui permet de voir qu'ils mettent en
perspective qui contextualise beaucoup
mieux est ce que la démence et le
football en général historiquement est
un peu en retard ou pour par exemple on
peut parler d'autres sports le sait que
sébastien par le basket ball par exemple
c'est un sport qui est décortiqué en
termes de stats alors peut-être que
c'est parce que c'était plus populaires
aux états unis et est ce que justement
c'est le football est un peu à la traîne
on peut dire par rapport à ses autres
sports c'est vrai que là on parle que du
football mais effectivement la notion de
data elle est présente dans dans dans
quasiment tous les sports aujourd'hui
même en cyclisme un petit peu en rugby
dans quasiment tous les sports on entend
parler de la data effectivement les
sports américains c'est là vraiment qui
est née quelle est la date assez des
états unis en particulier du baseball il
semble dans le foot américain dans le
basket c'est extrêmement présent
effectivement enzo parlait de deux
séquences sont des sports vraiment avec
des séquences très marqué qui sont
beaucoup moins fluide que le football
dans le basket ça était présent dès les
années dès les années 90 aujourd'hui
c'est hyper développé satan l'avancé
effectivement sur le sur le football
maintenant pour revenir à la france
effectivement la france un petit peu de
retard par exemple un pays comme
l'angleterre qui est un peu pionniers
j'irai en europe à ce niveau là c'est
antoine david qui est manager à ottawa
grand statistques grand statisticiens
sur sur le football qui m'expliquait
qu'il ya eu un peu un push depuis depuis
4 5 ans / / / le football français au
niveau de l'utilisation des
c'est à dire qu'au sein des clubs
aujourd'hui alors peut-être un autre tu
peux nous vous pouvez nous en parler un
peu plus mais il ya vraiment une mise en
place qui est fait au niveau des clubs
on s'est dit ça y est ça c'est le
terrain maintenant qu'il faut
comment dire qu'il faut à investir au
maximum
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs dogues ont en
rien sur certains clubs par rapport à la
question de la date assure le traitement
il faut savoir que pas tous les
responsables de recrutement sont à
l'aise avec l'outil data sont à l'aise
de confronter leurs regards football à
des données à des objectifs communs de
la data et donc du coup donnera pas de
noms je pense non non non non mais
encore une fois le but n'est pas de
de prêcher pour une paroisse ou de
critiquer lequel est bonne à qu'elle est
là qu elle ne l'est pas c'est même
d'ailleurs cohérent parle par le fait de
ne pas se confronter à des choses que
vous ne connais pas donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas de problème mais
aujourd'hui il y à des modèles en france
cela on peut citer des noms n'y a pas de
soucis comme le club de toulouse par
exemple qui base son processus de
recrutement par d'abord le data et ça
c'est vraiment original par exemple en
france
c'est alors c'est à dire qu'on va
recruter des joueurs alors avant de se
dire quels joueurs on va recruter on va
aller sur un site internet
/ / / des spécialisés ou grand public en
l'occurrence toulouse c'est même
beaucoup plus précis puisque ils ont
leur propre sac au rythme ils ont
développé leur propre façon de
d'algorithmes et les séquences le joueur
qu'on vienne à l'équipe le mieux pour le
moral en fait ils ont ils ont ils ont un
procès des six avec les algorithmes je
vais pas en dévoyé un peu là je préfère
laisser à damien comolli président du de
toulouse du tfc a détaillé ce processus
mais
si dans le rapport ça sort en b plus et
qu'il faut à moins minimum next en gros
il faut d'abord que ça rentre dans le
moule et dans le prisme
ddd de la 2d chiffres et ces chiffres
sont commuter par l'idée du coach par
l'idée du plan de jeu qui doit qui doit
correspondre
à ce qui doit être mis en place si ça
rentre pas là on peut rentrer dans
l'analyse terrain si ça rend si ça
rentre pardon là on peut réaliser là ça
rentre pas suivant c'est une c'est une
façon de voir c'est tout à fait nouveau
en france mais là dessus pour comprendre
des procédés aussi radicaux il a fallu
attendre voilà on parlait du baseball
est par exemple j'ai filmé money ball le
stratège qui justement montre avec les
hôtels et autant de lait oakland
athletics comment on est capable de
d'imaginer un management radicalement
basé sur la symétrie en l'occurrence
donc sur les indices les statistiques
avancées ben le money ball c'est 97 98
99 2000 2001 donc en france on attend de
2022 pour ça donc on a environ 20 ans de
retard en fait et c'est pas c'est pas
insulter la france 2 que de dire ça
parce que le football en général par
rapport au fait que le football est un
sport aux statistiques fluide
le football a beaucoup de retard par
rapport à d'autres sports sur les
statistiques avancées d'athènes aux
fellahs qui m'unit statistiquement
cinqueterre de ronaldo auront plus de
chance de faire un but que 20 tirs de
ryad boudebouz donc pour les
connaisseurs et effectivement des clubs
comme brentford
maxence dans les commentaires comme des
clubs comme prennent forme recrute
uniquement en se basant sur la sur la
data c'est quelque chose qui est plus
connu par internationale là on était
tous dans l'intervalle c'est quelque
chose qui marche si beaucoup ouais
effectivement l'angleterre c'est très
avancé brentford qui est un peu après
qu'eurent sera aussi à ce niveau là il
ya aussi le club norvégien si je dis pas
de bêtises de midtjylland d' je crois je
crois d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
effectivement qu'ils ont je crois
d'ailleurs le même voilà le même groupe
ii qui dirige brune ford et mini land
qui sont là dessus très avancé
maintenant pour revenir sur sur le tfc
ce qui est très intéressant aussi sur le
côté avant tout la data pour recruter
c'est ce qui explique julien de mots qui
en parle dans l'article qui est sorti
dans le journal ce matin qui explique
que lui en tout cas dans son rôle son
but c'est il va en fait il va jamais
regardé un match d'un joueur avant qu'il
ne signe pas ce que son travail à lui
spécifiquement c'est sur la data et donc
il estime qu'il peut donner 95% de son
avis peut être basée sur la date assuré
ce qu'on doit recruter ce joueur ou pas
après évidemment sans pour en parler
aussi le recrutement ne s'arrête pas là
il s'arrête pas derrière un ordinateur
derrière il ya tout un tas de personnes
au sein du club qui va aller voir le
joueur qui va le regarder plusieurs fois
match qui va le rencontrer et qui va se
faire un peu une idée aussi avec l'oeil
évidemment c'est très important et c'est
c'est derrière que toute la machine
ensuite va s'enclencher très solaire de
façon un peu pour provoquer statistiques
data le football devient inhumain il ya
une partie data et après cette partie
data il ya toujours des escales août qui
vont sur place des recruteurs qui
viennent voir le voir jouer mais en fait
justement la data a permis d'ouvrir des
frontières on parlait de midtjylland
justement midtjylland dette 1 était un
club
un épiphénomène dans le football jusqu'à
que manu sens car c'est justement le le
celui qui a amené ces processus
avec le groupe être brentford d'ailleurs
je vous invite à lire son livre les
hommes en effect qui est extrêmement
intéressant sur la capacité de recherche
de la performance donc humaines pour la
lier à la quantification jeu j'arrête ma
migration mais pour tout ça pour dire
quoi en fait c'est que la data a ouvert
des frontières a ouvert le monde a
ouvert l'europe simplement même je veux
même pas parler du monde à ovins
l'europe en se disant finalement quand
on regarde les chiffres quand on regarde
les données il y a des joueurs tout
aussi performant sur des marchés qui
sont toutes tout autant qu'ils sont
moins explorés que les cinq grands
championnats la france l'italie
l'allemagne l'angleterre et l'espagne
et qui sont capables de
d'apporter de la modernité de la
performance sur des points précis sur
des points techniques qui sont
compatibles avec l'alien là en
l'occurrence pendant les guerres mais
avec aussi d'autres championnats donc
non la data n'est pas là pour rendre le
foot inhumains au contraire il est là
pour
il a été là surtout parce qu'on va
parler des logiciels see what good wife
quarante et une stat il a été là aussi
pour explorer des terres de football qui
était inconnu jusqu'ici et donc au final
il a un rôle fondamentalement humain si
on réfléchit de cette manière là oui
c'est d'arriver à ouvrir et peut-être
recruter des joueurs je sais pas depuis
combien de temps toulouse par exemple
utilisent ce système et on a vu un
mercato on a de très belles réussites
ils sont premiers de ligue 2
actuellement il y voit monter d'ailleurs
ils vont monter c'est que c'est est ce
qu'on peut dire par contre que c'est un
gage de réussite
oui
mais pas aussi des exemples qui ne parle
pas un exemple qui ne marche pas très
bien parce qu'une ligue dans la même
ligue voilà aussi qui s'est pas mal basé
là dessus merci qui est dernier donc
exactement à l'opposé de toulouse qui va
descendre en national donc effectivement
ça ne suffit pas il faut encore les
bonnes paires nos bons endroits ils font
là il faut la bonne méthode de travail
et il suffit pas pour un club de se
mettre à la data pour que ça y est à
tous les étages tout marche tout seul
oui alors je vais je vais essayer de de
schématiser si il y à une coordination
une cohérence entre ce qui veut être mis
en place par le staff technique ce qui
veux m'y être mis en place par la
direction sportive sait qu'il va être
mis en place par la direction
là on a des chances d'avoir un cocktail
gagnant s'il ya des dissensions il ya
des façons de voir qu'ils sont
différentes et que tout le monde ne
travaille pas dans le même sens que ce
soit avec la data ou non il y aura des
couacs le il faut voir la data comme un
outil à du vent et d'un catalyseur de
votre projet de jeu
il faut prendre les éléments il faut
prendre les éléments comme comme une
capacité à transcender à aller voir plus
loin
ce que l'oeil humain peut dire donc au
final si vous avez des questions
football si vous avez des questions
techniques auxquelles la data peut
apporter une réponse concrète et
objective pourquoi s'en priver en fait
c'est c'est souvent un peu le problème
du prisme de français c'est la date
assez bien ou c'est pas bien on n'a pas
besoin du manichéisme en fait on a
besoin de considérer que c'est un outil
qui permet qu est complémentaire à ce
que peut voir à ce que peut voir ce que
peut avoir le humains ou alors tout
simplement l'oeil humain aussi peut être
complémentaire à ce que peu ce que peut
apporter la data c'est c'est surtout en
fait la coordination qui va faire qu'un
système va vous fonctionnez ou non
effectivement ligue 1 alors je reprends
ce qu'est ce qu'il dit dans l'article
données sensibles sujet sensible
actuellement il ya un témoignage anonyme
par exemple c'est le secret le mieux
gardé des clubs de foot actuellement
le secret le mieux gardé de la danse est
sûre bon je pense que je pense qu'il y
en a d'autres je pense pas que ce soit
la seule chose ont été les clubs se
cache un petit peu maintenant
effectivement c'est un sujet où les cas
ne veulent pas trop forcément livrer un
peu leurs secrets de la même manière
qu'on peut avoir un entraîneur en
conférence de presse qui va la jouer un
petit peu langue de bois sur quand vous
avez gagné ce match qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas marché qu'est ce que vous allez
faire pour gagner maintenant évidemment
on veut pas dévoiler tous les secrets
est là aussi chaque club fonctionne de
manière différente enzo le disait le tfc
a son propre algorithme d'autres clubs
fonctionnent comme ça ils ont parfois
les clubs achète la manière la matière
brute chez un fournisseur de données
typiquement opta pour ensuite le mettre
dans voilà stade bombe aussi qui est
assez développée là dessus et c'est un
budget conséquent pour un club oui bien
sûr bien sûr c'est je crois que c'est
justement pour ce stade donc je crois
qu'on estime à 1 par an si on veut les
données sur les clubs de ligue 1 ligue 2
c environ 15000 euros l'année et si on
veut un peu tous les championnats
européens ça peut monter à 90 milles
euros l'année ça c'est pour avoir la
donnée brute aussi après il faut faire
merci chevrère marché de tous les
logiciels et il faut aussi surtout de
faire payer les gens qui travaillent
derrière là dessus pour pour que le
résultat soit puisse aboutir font
comprendre que les clubs en fait sont
structurés comme des entreprises donc il
ya des budgets
si vous lancez votre budget pour la
cellule de recrutement qu'il est prévu
qui a pas de ligne de prévu pour acheter
des données brutes de stas bombes ou des
données métriques pour calculer des
kilomètres l'intensité on va vous dire
oui mais ça c'est pas prévu
comment comment va-t-on faire il faut qu
effectivement il faut il faut réfléchir
sur ok mais qu'est ce que ça va
m'apporter il faut pas le voir comme une
dépense il faut voir comme un
investissement et au final lorsque vous
achetez une machine à ultrasons lorsque
vous dans le club une machine ultra sons
une machine à cryogénisation qui va
coûter entre 50 et 200 mille euros pour
ça varie en fonction de ce que vous
voulez et que derrière vous voulez
investir sur des éléments qui vont nous
permettre d'avoir de la vence pour
quantifier mesurer ce que les joueurs du
monde entier vont pouvoir développer sur
le terrain est ce qu'au final
ne pas se tromper sur un transfert entre
1 2 3 4 millions d'euros est ce que ça
ne vaut pas la chandelle de d'investir
50 mille euros là dedans c'est comme ça
qu'il faut le voir en fait et
aujourd'hui la difficulté en fait vient
en fait de la rigidité des structures
qui vient pas forcément du club qui
vient en fait du cadre administratif
dans lequel ils sont fixés et au final
on se rend compte que oui ben
recrutement bat c'est comme ça bon bain
c'est en fait c'est le côté un peu
archaïque de se dire oui mais c'est
l'oeil c'est l'oeil d'igor dream est
d'accord l'oeil c'est bien et parfois il
faut confronter à la capacité à
capter beaucoup plus de données mais
plus le plus que tu se fait qu'on a on
ne peut pas avoir en une journée
regarder tous les matchs mais soutenant
les clubs et par exemple je sais pas
peut-être que vous pouvez nous parler de
votre expérience à reims par exemple
comment comment se passe une journée
type compte deux camps ont fait partie
de deux 2 nuls comme celle là alors je
vais pas parler de jouer au métier mais
je vais parler un petit peu en filigrane
de
comment
on construit une réflexion d'abord il ya
le projet de jeu de ce que l'on veut
mettre en place de ce que ce qui va
marcher de l'entraîneur qui va dire oui
voilà cette règle a effectué en 4 2 1 3
5 ou alors ça me saoule on peut parler
aussi de l'animation d'accord on va
jouer moi ce qui compte pour moi c'est
de ces de jouer direct de pouvoir jouer
d'être fort sur les transitions
défensive offensive et que ou alors que
si ça passe pas par une filière courte
sur les seconds ballons faut qu'on soit
là bref j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de
rentrer dans les détails techniques mais
le but c'est d'abord on a un projet de
jeu on sait ce qu'on veut mettre en
place en fonction de ça on va regarder
les matchs regardez les matchs vous
l'avez dit il y en a beaucoup et la data
nous a permis de voir beaucoup de
matches on me d'ouvrir beaucoup de
championnats comme et comme vous le
savez à reims on a on est on a eu le
courage la capacité de s'ouvrir à
beaucoup de championnat que ce soit en
europe par que ce soit leurs divisions
hollande la belgique le portugal bref le
danemark maintenant avec heinze cas
juste
qu'elle est grande recrue du mercato
hivernal pour djoko est tout à fait donc
du coup pour le coup on va on va aller
voir les matchs de tous et on va aller
voir tous ces matches mais par week-end
cela représente 50 60 70 matchs à
visionner en vidéo donc pas c'est bien
de se dire ok là on va essayer de tout
voir mais parfois on va louper quelque
chose parfois on va aller on va rater un
élément ou alors on va rater un match on
va rater une action l'oeil
s'il voit tous les matchs manière
assidue c'est magnifique c'est super
mais la data il va être capable de tout
compulser
sur tous les matches et donc du coup il
va avoir une capacité synthétique qui
peut permettre de réorienter de redire
de se dire ah tiens en fait là j'étais
toupet quelque chose là j'ai peut-être
j'ai peut-être
j'ai peut-être sous-estimé ou sur
estimer le potentiel ça donnait là donc
du coup c'est des éléments qui vont
permettre simplement de de
valoriser notre travail simplement de
valoriser le travail terrain le travail
de l'oeil c'est un outil complémentaire
je salue kriss kross qui vient de nous
rejoindre dans les commentaires on a
entendu un commentaire qui me dit de la
data ne mesure pas le mental du joueur
sachant que c'est une donnée importante
de pertes a été sébastien on vous a
parlé de ça dans les dents les dans les
différents dans différents témoignages
que vous avez aussi une fois qu'on a
fait cette étude statistique il faut
quand même voir comment réagit le joueur
et comment il est sur un terrain pour
s'adapter bien sûr la data elle prend
pas tous en compta prend pas le contexte
en compte c'est pour ça qu'il ya
justement quelqu'un derrière qui doit
regarder les mages qui doit essayer de
comprendre ses data pour la
contextualiser pour savoir ce qu elle ce
qu'elle nous dit concrètement est-ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut en apprendre
derrière il faut comprendre le
comportement du joueur son attitude ça
peut être son langage corporel toutes
ces choses là qu'on ne voit pas encore
avec les chiffres peut-être qu'on verra
un jour mais qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas avoir rencontré le joueur aussi se
rend compte de son de son tempérament un
petit peu de savoir quelle est sa
mentalité évidemment toutes ces choses
là on peut pas on peut pas les acquérir
en donner et c'est là aussi ensuite que
le travail des recruteurs à proprement
parler entre en jeu où on va vraiment
observer le joueur laissé le comprendre
de comprendre son entourage même
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup ce qui se
fait dans les clubs c'est pas juste dans
la vue le joueur il est bon c'est bon le
recrute hop mais un maillot et puis et
puis des routeurs sur terre c'est de
vraiment l'intégrer au club est de
savoir qui varient le club vous
travaillez
stade de reims ont travaillé beaucoup
sur la captation des seniors un verbe
haut c'est aussi davantage de se rendre
sur le terrain sur le terrain quand
quand un joueur loin de l'action fait un
geste d'humeur ou alors on vérifier
aussi s'il encourage ses coéquipiers ont
vérifié aussi si si les joueurs sont
réceptifs aux tons de gris parce que
c'est bien d'applaudir mais il faut
aussi que j'en ai l'impression qu'il ne
capacité à fédérer s'il ya du leadership
tous les éléments tous les signes non
verbaux qui capte le la détermination
qui capte le leadership ou la
capacité à résister à la pression le
tempérament vous avez un gardien il
prend un but comment ils réagissent
qu'il ya de sombrer s'il a l'air de
relever la tête ils ont peut amener
plein plein plein d'éléments
effectivement à partir du moment où on
enregistre ces données là ses débuts de
data en fait le fait de prendre et
d'enregistrer d'enregistrer le fait ses
débuts de de la data est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une différence
entre les différents alors on va parler
un peu entre les différents clubs il ya
différentes visions qui squattaient ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui du plus haut plus
bas qu'on m'ait d'analystes statistiques
pour les dans les clubs
alors c'est difficile de quantifier
parce que il va y avoir aussi des
dans certains clubs certaines missions
ponctuelles qui vont être effectués par
des entreprises qui
des entreprises qui qui embauchent des
ingénieurs qui ont fait pour certains
centrales en france mais ça peut être
plein de choses qui ont l'habitude de
l'étude de des probabilités qui parfois
elles mêmes ont travaillé auparavant
avec des sites de pari en ligne mais qui
aujourd'hui maintenant travail de plus
en plus avec les clubs pourraient dans
le prédictifs alors du coup bas ces
entreprises là emploi à 30 40 50
personnes il va y avoir sur des missions
ponctuelles
ces personnes qui ces entreprises qui
sont consultés et puis finalement les
clubs vont vont internaliser ça va
représenter
sur des chaudes et sur des personnes
itinérantes 20 à 30 personnes puis à
l'intérieur aux deux clubs savent être
cinq six sept huit personnes c'est très
compliqué de quantifier parce que c'est
très fluide en fait c'est très émouvant
oui on peut imaginer vous imaginez avant
le mercato par exemple ou des choses qui
se mettent en place et une cellule qui
va grossir ce mois oui on peut imaginer
aussi on peut imaginer aussi
et un nouveau staff un nouveau projet
dieu donc faut tout refaire en fait il
ya plein de plein de possibilités qui
amène ses réflexions et sébastien on va
très bien dans son papier
chaque
chaque club a son utilisation et son et
son utilité sur la réflexion de la date
à ce qu'il faut prendre en compte aussi
c'est que maintenant très peu
d'analystes travail sans la date du tout
c'est un outil qui est presque obligé
aujourd'hui en 2022 en tout cas d'avoir
dans son arsenal maintenant pour donner
un peu une ordre d'idée part pour les
clubs les plus grands clubs d'europe en
tout cas les plus avancés âge là dans la
data je pense notamment à liverpool ou
manchester city qui ont département
alloués à ça ça peut être une dizaine de
personnes qui sont vraiment consacré à
ce secteur là
j'avais déjà vu une autre question que
je suis j'étais hors d'ordre est ce ce
métier finalement dans l'est dans les
clubs on l'a dit alors il est pas tout
récent non plus mais il se développe de
plus en plus comment on fait au final
pour pour devenir
le mathématicien du club qui va faire
les recrutements on va dire pour pour
schématiser
là dessus je crois pas qu'il ya en tout
cas en france encore deux formations
vraiment spécialisés un petit peu plus
en angleterre il ya un peu plus d des
possibilités de diplômes à ce niveau là
en france il y avait la possibilité de
faire staps qui est un peu le classique
quand on aime le sport mais c'est pas
juste juste comme ça je crois qu'il a un
master à l'insep si je dis pas de
bêtises aujourd'hui qui permet un peu de
ce seul ans un peu plus dans les
sciences les sciences sportives comme
comme on appelle ça maintenant je pense
que je connais un petit peu plus le
mieux que moi en tout cas pour vraiment
s'engouffrer après danser dans ces
postes là combien je vais pas faire de
promotion est vraiment j'ai lancé j'ai
lancé en collaboration
avec le magazine vestiaires et formation
en ligne sur le sujet de parce que
justement c'est vrai que en france et
très peu de référentiels sur les
formations pour les problèmes et y est
dur pour les pour délivrer les
compétences en tant que entend le métier
de recruteur est dans le métier de
analyste vidéo donc oui effectivement
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
n'est qui n'est pas encore démocratisée
et c'est vrai que par exemple au
portugal
on apprend les diplômes d'éducateur on
les apprend à l'université et il ya tout
il ya tout un développement avec le
travail de vie tu en feras des qui est
le père de la périodisation tactique sur
sur la transmission des connaissances
sur les bancs d'école sur les bancs des
universités en france on a encore cette
culture du terrain du terrain du terrain
qui est héritée de la directeur des
travaux de georges boulogne avec les
directions des comptes nationale sans
parler de dogme si c'est bien ou c'est
pas bien parfois il est dans le prisme
d'aujourd'hui on a besoin de deux
théories mais pour revenir à votre à
votre question analyse vidéo
effectivement c'est un métier qui est
pas qu'ils aient pas si récent mais ce
qui est intéressant ou analystes tout
court analyse du recrutement ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui c'est la
diversification des profils aujourd'hui
un moment donné ont recruté des anciens
éducateurs puis après on l'a recruté un
ancien analyste vidéo qui était qui
avait l'habitude d'effectuer du montage
vidéo donc avec une science de l'image
et aujourd'hui on a carrément une
science de la probabilité donc on va
recruter des personnes qui ont fait
polytechnique qui ont fait central qui
ont fait parfois même des sens
astrophysique pour être pour être sûr
que lorsqu'on étudie une probabilité ce
qu en astrophysique si vous vous trompez
d'un millimètre vous trompez de planète
donc c'est un peu bas c'est un peu le
même principe lorsqu'on va sortir 6
millions de données il ya des six
millions sont exactes donc du coup on va
on va faire appel à des astrophysiciens
qui sont extrêmement précis à la virgule
près pour pour être clair sur sur ce
qu'on va vouloir schématiser mais tu
remplaces compulser donc ça c'est ça la
nouveauté en fait dit à deux trois
quatre cinq ans comment vous vous êtes
arrivé dans ce milieu là à kaka qu'elles
vont vous été dit tiens c'est c'est ça
que je veux faire c'est une longue
histoire sinon j'en parle un peu
autodidacte et là dessus je remercie
toutes les personnes qui m'ont fait
confiance pour m'amener pour moi mais
pour m'amener ici donc j'ai auparavant
travaillé comme comme recruteur pour une
agence de joueurs et puis au fur et à
mesure ça s'est développé sur du
consulting et le consulting s'est
développée après pour pour le reste a
rejeté resta de la suite de recrutement
aurait star et après la promotion plus
la rélégation du red star j'ai été donc
sollicité par le stade de reims pour
pouvoir les rejoindre en avril 2019 et
voilà maintenant aujourd'hui en 2022
j'ai tous les chausse trappes et tous
les écueils que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai
connu dans ma jeune carrière et bien
j'essaye de l'est de les transmettre au
maximum dans mes nouveaux projets
d'aujourd'hui alors on n'a pas ça qui me
dit quand on regarde le modèle de
recrutement de liverpool on comprend
mieux l'utilité des sciences il se
trouve une fois sur dix et encore c'est
qu'on modèle en termes de recrutement
alors sans savoir forcément si c'est
grâce à ça ou pas parce qu'on fasse on
n'a pas le modèle inverse oui ou où ils
n'auraient pas où ils n'auraient pas que
ça mais effectivement on voit que ce
club là en terme de recrutement il ya
quand même très peu de fois où ça ne
marche pas du tout oui et aussi parce
que il y a une façon de recruter qui est
basée sur un modèle de jeu kane pressing
le con tre pressing les écoles du con
tre pressing de jürgen klopp qui est
extrêmement structurée ça veut dire
il ya ralf rangnick qui qui qui
racontait sa à l'époque gouvernée qui
est grave un front uni qui est
aujourd'hui le l'entraîneur de
manchester united mais qui est aussi un
des fondateurs du modèle red bull est
aussi un des fondateurs et théoricien
des méthodes sur le guen pressing qui
est cette fameuse école allemande ou en
gros vous perdez la balle et je vais
vraiment être schématique haut possible
vous perdez la balle vous avez six
secondes pour récupérer ballon que je
sois côté malo ou pas et en gros vous
vous débrouillez vous donner l'info pour
le bras exactement possible tant et si
bien qu à hoffenheim aucun des clubs qui
est on va dire le berceau du game
tracing il y avait un chronomètre géant
pour à la perte de balle dire six
secondes il y avait un gong il y avait
un gong au bout des six secondes pour
récupérer le ballon
bref tout ça pour revenir au fait que
liverpool l'intelligence de liverpool
c'est d'avoir amené un modèle de
recrutement qui complètement
fondamentalement adaptées aux qualités
au point fort du jeu de jürgen klopp qui
est très spécifique donc c'est pour ça
que vous avez en attaque
des joueurs comme mohamed salah comme ça
du manet comme roberto firmino
aujourd'hui de du gothard même lousiane
de porto qui correspondent parfaitement
à ce jeu de transition extrêmement
efficient peut-être le plus efficient de
tous les temps payant par peur de le
dire
et par rapport à par rapport à ça
l'intelligent de liverpool c'est surtout
voilà assis d'avoir amené tous les
moyens ce soit physique
métriques
statistiques pour théoriser le
recrutement dans ce projet de jeu là
c'est là où on fait liverpool est à la
pointe aujourd'hui c'est d'amener des
datas adapté au football elle est là la
révolution du foot de la data 3.0 elle
est là la vraie révolution c'est que
aujourd'hui avant on avait des data pour
comme des faits qu'on nous assène
aujourd'hui celle inverse veut dire que
vont faire en sorte que la data s'adapte
à ce que l'on a réfléchi et là on allège
et qu'elle donne le ton effectivement
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
avant était avec moi en direct se
rappelle sébastien ferra votre article
comment les data sont en train de
révolutionner la ligue 1 je pense qu'on
vous l'a bien expliqué disponible à
plein d'infos intéressantes dedans à les
lire sur le site du figaro allait
acheter le journal bien évidemment merci
à julien qu'une aile à la réalisation
évidemment l eau des ben ali et
responsable adjoint de la cellule de
recrutement du stade de reims merci
aussi d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
livrer un peu tout tout tout tout ce qui
se passe en coulisses dans les clubs
effectivement à 10 18 heures vous avez
rendez vous avec point de vue avec
vincent roux à la présentation à 20
heures c'est le club biarrot pour
revendre à des législatives de
politiques plus de sport effectivement
et moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux lives d'en finir là